my name is john bristol and i'm from
chilean tobago i'm the director of
superfresh and today i'm going to show
you how we clean the very dirty
mattresses as well as the average dirty
ones
so a typical process for cleaning a
mattress is respiring an enzyme based
cleaner and that will break down the
dirt and the body oils and you know the
incidence and we give that chemical some
time to work after that there's some
agitation also known as scrubbing
and in the final stage of the process we
use the extractor and that would spray
in a solution of clean water fabric
shampoo and deodorizer and vacuum at the
same time so it rinses away everything
so there isn't any harsh chemicals left
to interfere with anyone's skin or
anything afterwards
there's going to be a lot of dust build
up over time um there's going to be here
if there are a lot of kids in your home
you're going you're going to find you're
in even if the client doesn't know
sometimes like you know some people eat
on their beds and stuff say fine crumbs
from various food stuff
all right so i actually had no idea what
to expect when coming to do this job and
i'm still not entirely sure what caused
it it may have been some flooding in the
area but i'm not sure so that was
probably more than five years for sure
so right here i am spraying on the
enzyme base cleaner onto the mattress
and i'm looking to see the areas where i
may have to apply another coat as we go
along
what i use right now it's a synthetic
enzyme i could use it for everything but
there are some stains that would require
like additional chemicals if you really
want to get them removed visually but
the most important thing for most
clients is getting the actual thing that
causes stain outs so you say it may not
be a visual improvement but you can be
sure that you're getting all the nasties
out
they are usually just regular build-up
so just regular dust and dirt that
accumulate over the years some clients
don't use like a full three-piece sheet
set on our clients don't have much as
protectors either
using heat is beneficial because heat
acts almost like a universal catalyst so
heat would help your chemicals to work
faster so it would help the enzyme
cleaner to break down your stuff faster
and also help the fabric shampoo to
latch onto the dirt particles faster so
it helps make the cleaning process more
efficient unfortunately there's no way
to know for sure that you get like a
hundred percent of it where you wanna
know that you're picking up as much as
possible
this mattress was especially dirty so
it's either like a lot of years probably
more than seven or so or a lot of use
but i don't think it's any one thing but
just like a combination of factors that
leaves it to be that condition i found
that you could use a variable speed
polisher and a scrubbing brush
attachment the brushes rotating at about
600 rpm we use the softest brush
available because some fabrics are
really delicate
and we use that to help break down the
larger debris and stuff on the surface
of the fabric so it helps prevent the
larger pieces of debris because
sometimes they have build up that is
really really bad and it's actually like
kicked up
and the general process for moving
steams
is just there isolate where the stain is
and i mean double apply the enzyme based
cleaner to it or i may spend a little
longer scrubbing it
i believe for this one client told us it
was probably about two years
and it wasn't too bad it was just like a
light a creamish color but we know the
original color was white so we sprayed
it one time and we did the scrubbing
i mean you'll always have the extremes
some would be much much darker brown
some would be much more spotty but the
average person is you know just a little
cream just a little off-white
from where it should be
the mattresses are usually going to get
those kind of colors because even below
the surface they still have a lot of
debris your dead skin cells your dirt
and your dust building up so even if the
top surface doesn't accurately represent
what is hidden inside there you're gonna
find it once we do the extraction
[Music]
after a certain amount of years your
mattress
significantly increases in weight simply
due to like the dust and dead skin cells
that collect so one is going to be more
uncomfortable too if you're using it
regularly some of that is going to be
entering the air so you're going to have
like a lower quality inside the home it
may attract mites there's a lot of
moisture around just overall is not
going to be the best for your well-being
like for people that are asthmatic the
buildup of dust could be a problem for
people with shattered skin any build-up
on your mattress over time could pose a
threat in your future in terms of like
having flare-ups if you're taking only
preventative measures i don't think you
should need to service more than like
once a year get it cleaned and then get
a mattress protector because you can
always wash that every fourth night or
every month and you're in a much better
position than paying me and i don't mind
but in a much better position for you
and well-being